Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. You are
busy with the worldly affairs until you
visit the graves. Brothers and sisters,
Masjid Norway, the one that we built is
looking to another Masjid around the
area of Norway subhanallah where there's
so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This Masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your akhirah because
when you enter that grave, nobody's
going to remember you except Allah
subhanallah wa ta'ala. And believe me if
every single one of us give £1, £10,
£100, £1,000, that's going to be
something you will never regret on Yawm
al-Qiyamah and everything that you lose
is going to perish and go.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Mishary has done a video
um against Iran. I mean, I did not know
he would take this move, but he's done
the video and hamdulillah I saw the
video and sent it to my channel. Before
I started I subscribed to his channel as
well and he sent me the translations
himself and I really appreciate it from
him. May Allah bless and preserve him
inshallah. I came across the video
through his channel subhanallah. So you
can keep up to date with current affairs
etc. So here is the video. I'm going to
play it for you guys. We're going to
watch it for ourselves and we're going
to go through what the lyrics stand for.
Now,
I mean,
we're going to go through lyrics a bit
by bit. Let's just dissect it and be
like, "Hold on a second. Is Mishary
right or wrong for doing this?" So I
hope you guys are ready with me as much
as I am. Here is the nasheed for itself.
I've changed the lyrical speed it up a
bit. I've put the sound down a bit uh so
we don't get banned for copyright and
I'm going to not play the whole play the
whole thing. So here it goes.
>> I mean I got to love the fact that
Mishary has put himself in the in the
pilot seat. I found that bit hilarious,
I'm not going to lie, but let's carry
on.
Okay, we don't need to watch the whole
thing, child. Let's go through the
translation of what is actually being
said here. It goes,
"The Iranophiles were more outraged by
the poem, 'Perish the hands of Iran',
than
than Iran than Iran itself."
Okay. Now, we spoke about this before. I
don't want to repeat myself, but you
need to understand uh the Shiites in
Iran have known in history
to always backstab the Sunni Muslims and
be after them and massacre them. Let's
Let's Let's be honest with you. I mean,
this this is in history. This is
reality. I'm not saying every Shiite is
like that. I'm not saying that, and
there have been Sunnis who have
committed atrocities as well. So, okay,
we're not we're not we're not justifying
both. We're just saying that they have
been very very hard
against and very staunch uh the uh
um
How can I explain? Vicious against the
Sunnis. So, the last it says that they
twist words and distort their meaning,
"For if they defend your land against
the Iranian aggressor, for
they claim you stand with Zionists."
Again, I've said it before and I'll say
it again. I'm I have no I have no
criticism with Mishary
uh with this nashid as well, maybe for
certain stuff, but here he's correct.
Just because you are against Iran like
I'm against Iran of what they've done to
Sunni Muslims in Syria and other places
around the world, this doesn't mean that
I'm going to align with them and mean
I'm a Zionist. Anyone that comes and
says that and I'm so sorry, you're being
disingenuous. So, here he's right. And
then he says, uh "They fail to realize
that they are sitting with those who
slaughter their own brothers in the
Gulf."
Uh Gulf. "Just as they have done in
Syria and elsewhere. Correct, but this
statement can same someone can be there
was African they can say well you're
doing the same thing. And Mishary which
is my criticism is why didn't you do any
initiative about the Palestinians?
Let's be honest, why did you not do any
mockery and like this against the
Palestinians against Zionists?
Why didn't you? We condemn Iran
attacking the Gulf and Muslim countries
especially the
the holy lands, the land of Tawhid.
Let's be honest, they're attacking the
etc. I was going there for Umrah and I
saw certain airplanes with thing our
plane could have get hit forever for
whatever uh reason. So I'm 100%
understand Mishary.
However, why did you not ever do
something like this for the Palestinian
people? We have to be just here. And
yes, you been opposed against Iran as
much as I am, doesn't make you a
Zionist, but also when it comes between
the Zionist and Iran we're on Iran's
side. With all due respect, theological
we are closer to them than these the
Zionist comeback.
Um and then it carries on, have they
have they been had they been sincere,
they would have defended the land uh
that holds Mecca and Medina at the very
least.
True. Yes, I believe they would have
they shouldn't have get them involved in
this and again I don't know the
geopolitics. I don't know if whatever
they can justify that as again
again
And then it goes the Persian rose
against us from every battlefield. They
charged swift across the lands between
the sea and the clouds. They struck us
with treachery before the light of dawn
had been broken before the morning
prayer while the night remained pitch
black. Perish the hands of Iran and also
who stands with Iran. We are the people
of monotheism, the very symbol of gallon
country.
We also confronted them from the east
all the way to Oman by the grace of my
Lord and by the grace of our leadership.
Okay, so then it goes around uh praising
the leaders etc. Perish the hands of
Iran etc. etc. etc. You get the gist of
the nasheed. The issue here is the
following. Like I said to you before
guys
if we are against Zionists and what
they're doing to our brothers and
sisters in Palestine, we also have to be
against Iran and what they've done to
Sunni Muslims. They have killed maybe as
much or if not more Sunni Muslims in
Syria. This is a fact. You have to be
real to yourself. Okay, I can't come and
lie. I'm just trying my best to be
unbiased and speak the truth. Uh so in
that aspect, yes, them attacking the,
you know, the holy lands, etc. I'm not
saying the holy places, etc. Again, I
believe it's wrong. Okay? And anyone in
the Gulf countries, etc. who are
innocent people like attacking airports,
etc. This is uncalled for. The attack
against Zionists, we are on board with
them. So, I'll be honest with you, my
main criticism of this Nasheed is why
Mishary did not do a single one about
Palestinians.
Not a single Nasheed against
Palestinians. For our brother for for
our brother and sister in Palestine.
But when it comes to Iran attacking
their own country, they speak about it.
And then
rightly so, you will say, "Okay, yep.
You know, he's right. He should be doing
it, etc." But then the Palestinians,
when they defend themselves, you know,
and they have UN charters backing them
up as well,
then they they it's dead silent. This is
the hypocrisy. This is This is sadly
this is where I would give my criticism
in a nutshell.
There's nothing else needs to be said
for my sisters. I'll be honest with you.
It is uh I understand Mishary doing this
video. It is wholly innocent to
understand. His people have been
attacked, etc. Well, then the same thing
applies to the Palestinians. That's my
only criticism in this. I'll be honest
with you. And my ballot my my approach
is again the same. Uh and you know, uh
nothing else needs to be said, guys. I
can't say nothing else with this matter.
I just brought it to your attention,
inshallah. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.